love to laugh you're in luck because
some of the best comedies ever made are
getting sequels and they're coming
sooner than you think
[Music]
a third sequel to Ghostbusters was on
the table for decades and while Dan
Aykroyd certainly had ambitious plans
for the franchise they sadly never
panned out instead fans got a reboot
with Paul feig's 2016 Ghostbusters which
featured a whole new set of Ghostbusters
played by Kristen Wiig Kate McKinnon
Leslie Jones and Melissa McCarthy that
film's middling box office returns and
so-so critical reviews ensured that it
would never receive any sequels and so
Sony rebooted Ghostbusters once more
with 2021's Ghostbusters afterlife set
in the world of the original
Ghostbusters films and featuring cameos
from both living and not so living
members of the original team the film
was a hit at the relatively subdued
coveted era box office prompting Sony to
green light a sequel Jason Reitman
director of Ghostbusters afterlife and
Son of original Ghostbusters director
Ivan Reitman will return to co-write and
produce an afterlife sequel which is
reportedly titled to Ghostbusters
Firehouse co-writing duties also go to
Monster House's Gil Keenan as the end
sequence of afterlife suggests the film
will take place in New York City just
like the 80s Ghostbusters films while a
few cast members will be returning from
afterlife it hasn't yet been confirmed
whether Bill Murray Dan Aykroyd Ernie
Hudson or Rick Moranis might return but
fans are no doubt hoping for the best
on a series of sketches from
Nickelodeon's all that Keenan and Kel's
good burger hit movie theaters in 1997.
welcome to Good Burger home of the Good
Burger can I take your order the Good
Burger movie which revolves around a
rivalry between the Good Burger fast
food joint and a soulless corporate
chain earned a modest 23 million dollars
at the box office but Nostalgia home
video frequent airings on TV and Keenan
Thompson's rise as an iconic pop culture
figure have turned the film into a cult
classic Paramount took note of this and
put in an order for some more good
burger in March 2023 set to debut on
Paramount plus sometime in 2023 Good
Burger 2 will follow a Down and Out
Dexter as he returns to Good Burger to
work alongside Ed who's still employed
at the restaurant decades later along
with Thompson and Mitchell Carmen
Electra will return as the would-be
secret sauce recipe Thief Roxanne will
the movie enjoy the cult following of
the original your guess is as good as
ours but here's hoping Good Burger 2
makes for good eating either way
in 2002 My Big Fat Greek Wedding became
a pop culture phenomenon as huge as it
was unexpected the story originally
began as a semi-autobiographical
one-woman show written and performed by
Nia verdalos actor and producer Rita
Wilson saw it and loved it and soon
enough so did her husband Tom Hanks a
few years later they co-produced the
film adaptation a blockbuster that
grossed 368 million dollars worldwide
making it the highest earning romantic
comedy of all time My Big Fat Greek
Wedding led to a follow-up movie My Big
Fat Greek Wedding 2 as well as a
spin-off on CBS in June 2022 verdellos
announced in an Instagram video the
third movie had already begun filming on
location in Greece filming wrapped two
months later vardalos directs the movie
and reprises the leading role of Tula at
the same time according to US Weekly a
host of original cast members will also
return including John Corbett Elena
camporis Andrea Martin Louis Mandalore
and Maria vicratzis according to the
movie's trailer the sequel finds the
porticolos family visiting Greece
fulfilling a dying wish of patriarch Gus
who wanted his descendants to experience
the village in which he was raised My
Big Fat Greek Wedding 3 is due for
release on September 8 2023
considering the pile of films from the
80s and 90s being reimagined for modern
audiences it was always going to be a
matter of time before the bizarre 1988
Tim Burton haunted house comedy
Beetlejuice got the sequel treatment
sure enough Beetlejuice 2 is finally in
the works it's showtime Warner Brothers
confirmed that development on the movie
had begun at cinemacon 2023 soon after
it was announced that Wednesday's Jenna
Ortega had joined the cast reportedly
playing the daughter of Winona Ryder's
character from the first movie it has
also been reported that Michael Keaton
is returning to reprise his iconic turn
as Beetlejuice himself he'll be joined
here by returning cast members Ryder and
Catherine O'Hara with newcomer Monica
Bellucci playing his wife and Justin
Thoreau playing an unknown character
apparently Willem Dafoe is also set to
play some sort of afterlife cop while
little is known about the plot we do
know that Burton himself is coming back
to direct Beetlejuice 2 is tentatively
earmarked for a September 6 2024 release
date but production delays caused by
after strike could feasibly push the
movie Down the Line
Roger Ebert once hailed This Is Spinal
Tap as one of the funniest movies ever
made and it's difficult to disagree with
him the 1984 mockumentary tells the
story of fading band Spinal Tap
desperately searching for musical glory
in a world that has forgotten them as
they embark on a tour across the United
States they're filmed by the not so
talented documentarian Marty played by
the film's actual director Rob Reiner
with it's so terrible they're amazing
songs and countless improvised jokes
it's no wonder that this is spinal tap
became an instant classic and now Reiner
is getting the band back together
original Stars Michael McKean
Christopher Guest and Harry Shearer will
be picking up their guitars and rocking
round Stonehenge in the film's upcoming
sequels scheduled for release in 2024.
right in time for The Originals 40th
anniversary here's hoping they can turn
this sequel up to 11.
we appear to be in the midst of an Eddie
Murphy Renaissance after gradually
fading from the spotlight since his
Heyday in the 80s and early 90s Murphy
is suddenly back in a big way in the
last few years he gave a critically
acclaimed performance in 2019's Dolomite
is my name made a triumphant return to
Saturday Night Live as host lined up new
stand-up comedy specials for Netflix and
announced a sequel to one of his biggest
hits from the 80s Beverly Hills Cop will
you go put your trunks on and get in
this pool marking the fourth installment
in the Beverly Hills Cop franchise this
newest sequel will also be a
collaboration between Murphy and Netflix
after Paramount previously pulled the
plug on a planned Beverly Hills Cop 4
back in 2016. Murphy will be reprising
his role as Axel Foley the Detroit cop
who repeatedly finds himself traveling
to Beverly Hills to investigate various
crimes Beverly Hills Cop 4 was
originally going to be directed by Bad
Boys for Life directors Adil lrb and
Bilal fala but after they dropped out to
focus on Batgirl the job went to mark
Lloyd a rising filmmaker who has gained
attention for his Apple commercials as
for the screenplay Murphy previously
said he is ready to go as soon as the
script is complete and in August 2022
deadline reported that will Beale best
known for story credits on Aquaman and
Zack Snyder's Justice League had joined
Axel Foley this time Murphy and his
fellow Beverly Hills Cop veterans will
be joined by Kevin Bacon Joseph
Gordon-Levitt and Zola breakout star
Taylor Page
considering the runaway success of
2018's crazy Rich Asians it would be
surprising if the film didn't earn a
sequel well as it happens it's actually
getting two based on Kevin Kwan's books
of the same names China rich girlfriend
and rich people problems are both moving
ahead at Warner Brothers although it may
be a while before we get to see them due
to the busy schedules of the franchise's
A-list cast and director John M Chu the
next two installments in the crazy rich
Asian Saga probably won't be coming
anytime soon it seems like the scripts
aren't even completed yet Michelle yo
told E news we are still waiting on it
we know there's a writer on it so we'll
see that writer according to deadline
will be from scratch's Amy Wang who
replaces the original film scribes Peter
chiarelli and Adele Lim meanwhile
producer Nina Jacobson says that the
plan is to shoot both sequels back to
back so that fans are waiting years
between the second and third films
Jacobson admits there will likely be a
wait for the sequels but ads we'll make
it up to them on the back end by
shooting two films together
if you can dodge a wrench you can dodge
a ball what
it's been two decades since the
so-called frat pack dominated Hollywood
comedy Ben Stiller and Vince Vaughn
stalwarts of that scene collaborated on
many mid-2000s movies perhaps most
notable of which was 2004's dodgeball A
True Underdog Story a broad and wacky
sports movie that simultaneously
satirizes sports movie cliches dodgeball
is a tale of good versus evil set on the
dodgeball court dodgeball wraps up
pretty conclusively but since it was a
massively profitable hit and an enduring
favorite on cable TV a sequel is on the
way regardless in April 2023 deadline
reported that 20th century Studios had
ordered another round of dodgeball the
binge screenwriter Jordan vandina Will
pen the script taking over from original
writer director Ross and Marshall
Thurber a director for this movie is yet
to be announced but Vaughn has already
agreed to reprise his role from the
first dodgeball having successfully
pitched his original idea for the movie
to vandina
Freaky Friday follows a mother and
daughter who after magically switching
bodies come to understand one another
better after literally spending some
time in each other's shoes it's a
formula that is easily replicated as
evidenced by the multiple versions of
the movie released in 1976 1995 and
2018. the 2003 take which stars Jamie
Lee Curtis as stressed out mother Tess
Coleman and Lindsay Lohan as wannabe
Rockstar daughter Anna Coleman earned
160 million dollars at the box office
and launched Lohan's post-childhood
career on the awards show circuit for
2022's everything everywhere all at once
Curtis repeatedly mentioned that she'd
like to play Tess Coleman again and
suggested that she had already engaged
in preliminary talks with Disney about a
sequel the movie became official in May
2023 when Curtis and Lohan announced
Freaky Friday 2 in a New York Times
retrospective on the first film short
film a tour Elise Hollander has been
hired to write the screenplay and what
will be her first feature-length project
it's been over 20 years since audiences
followed effervescent Sorority Girl L
Woods to Harvard Law School in the
bubblegum comedy Legally Blonde Elle
Wood
welcome to Harvard she continued to
ascend the professional ladder in 2003's
Legally Blonde 2 red white and blonde
which saw Elle head to Washington DC now
Elle is back in addition to starring as
L Reese Witherspoon will also act as a
producer this time through her hello
sunshine banner and she's brought on
never have I ever created Mindy Kaling
and Brooklyn nine-nine's Dan Gore to pen
the screenplay also returning for the
sequel is Jennifer Coolidge who starred
in both previous films as Elle's friend
Paulette a character who Kaling teased
will have a really juicy role in the
film as for the rest of the original
cast we are still not sure who will be
returning but we do know that there will
be a lot of new faces in Legally Blonde
3 along with a lot more diversity Kaling
promises reflecting the world as it is
now is something that's really important
to Rhys and so having there be diversity
is super super important you can
definitely count on that we've yet to
hear much in the way of plot details but
as a big fan of the original films
Kaling is very much looking forward to
revisiting an older and wiser L Woods
she says I can't wait to see what people
will think of the way we wrote L Woods
at 40. how L Woods is at 40 versus how
she was at 21 has been really fun to
imagine
in an act of Divine Providence or maybe
just Hollywood Nostalgia it looks like
Sister Mary Clarence will be donning her
habit once again Sister Act 3 will
premiere on Disney plus sometime in the
near future Whoopi Goldberg will indeed
be returning as both star and producer
with Tyler Perry also coming on board to
produce Madhuri shakar signing on to pen
the script and High School Musical the
musical the series Creator Tim fetterly
attached to direct released in 1992 the
first Sister Act saw Goldberg play
Dolores van Cartier a lounge singer who
goes in to witness protection at a
Convent after witnessing a murder Sister
Act got a sequel in 1993 with Sister Act
2 back in the habit which found Dolores
stepping in as a music teacher for a
group of low achieving students at a
Catholic School Goldberg suggested in
her profile for variety in 2021 that we
could even possibly see some of those
kids again she said maybe there's going
to be some of the kids from Sister Act
2. who can say the rest of the cast is
up in the air right now but sister X3 is
certainly heading in the right direction
but it has a whole lot of adults to go
through so if they don't uh get in its
way it could actually be pretty good
fans of the 1996 bowling comedy Kingpin
will be glad to hear that a sequel is
rolling down the pipeline the original
film starred Woody Harrelson as a former
bowling Prodigy who believes he has
found his claim to fame when he
discovers an Amish bowling Superstar
played by Randy Quaid the movie also
starred Bill Murray as Harrelson's
lifelong rival no details have yet been
revealed about the sequel other than the
fact that Peter and Bobby Farrelly who
directed the first film will be back on
board to produce however it's unclear
whether the Farrelly brothers are
intending to write or direct the sequel
in addition to their producing duties
similarly none of the original cast is
confirmed to be returning for the sequel
although fans would surely welcome
another chance to see Harrelson and
Murray unite on the big screen
ready for another trip to Genovia it
certainly looks like Disney is preparing
for a new royal adventure with the
princess diaries 3. we don't know any
plot details yet and it doesn't look
like anyone has been officially cast as
of this moment however Anne Hathaway has
expressed her desire for a streak will
in the past so chances are good she'll
be returning to play Mia Thermopolis for
her part it seems like Julie Andrews
plans on sitting this one out as she
told The Hollywood Reporter in June 2022
for especially me it's too far down the
line now to go back to it it's a lovely
thought but I don't think it would
probably be possible
now one of the most beloved stars to
have ever kicked his way across the
Silver Screen Jackie Chan first found
Hollywood's success with the action
comedy Rush Hour the 1998 film paired
Chan's martial arts Savvy Hong Kong
detective with Chris Tucker's riotus La
cop together Chan and Tucker starred in
the eighth highest grossing movie of the
year and kicked off two sequels in the
process and now a third is on the way at
the Red Sea International Film Festival
Jackie Chan revealed that he's in talks
to make Rush Hour four he added that he
was about to go talk with the director
about the upcoming film although he
didn't reveal the filmmaker's identity
the previous installments in the series
were all helmed by Brett Ratner but as
Ratner is now a persona non grata in
Hollywood a new director is likely to be
stepping up to bat despite Ratner
claiming he was making Rush Hour 4 back
in 2018 however it does at least look
like Tucker is coming back speaking with
v103's Big Tigger Morning Show he talked
about his upcoming work schedule a Rush
Hour 4 that's something I definitely
will probably drop in there because I
love working with Jackie no due date yet
but it seems Rush Hour 4 is certainly on
the way
one of the definitive films of the 1990s
election is a pitch black satire that
takes aim at the U.S political system
through the lens of a high school
election the movie finds Reese
Witherspoon's Tracy flick tirelessly
campaigning to become student body
president and doing whatever it takes to
win all the while bitter teacher Jim
McAllister is desperately trying to
destroy Tracy's chances of earning any
votes now all these years later it looks
like Tracy flick is coming back
determined as ever to be number one
Tracy flick can't win will reunite
Witherspoon with Alexander Payne the
original movie's director the project is
based on the novel by Tom perrotta which
finds flake back at high school trying
to become principal while struggling
with a life that hasn't panned out how
she planned while we don't have a
release date yet expect the election
sequel to campaign its way to Paramount
plus sometime in the future
Hocus Pocus was only a moderate hit
during its initial theatrical release in
1993. a Halloween movie released in July
for some reason it earned around 45
million dollars at the box office but it
became a hit on home video and through
repeated heavily watched annual TV
broadcasts by the early 2000s Hocus
Pocus had become required October
viewing for countless viewers it tells
the story of teenager Max who along with
his little sister Danny and Crush
Allison attempt to prevent the return of
a trio of evil witches debuting in
September 2022 Hocus Pocus 2 set a
viewership record for Disney plus
racking up 2.73 billion minutes of watch
time over its first three days of
availability and now a third Hocus Pocus
is flying over to Disney Plus 2. in June
2023 Disney Executives Sean Bailey told
the New York Times that a third entry in
the comedic witch series was in the
works
thank you